former president Donald Trump will make
history today when he appears in a
Florida Court as you've heard he faces
37 Federal accounts related to the
alleged mishandling of some of America's
most closely guarded National Security
Secrets he is expected to plead not
guilty and he's getting a lot of support
from fellow Republicans only on CBS
morning's former speaker that would be
Paul Ryan is here to talk about that
some other things that were mulling over
today at the table he was a Republican's
Vice Presidential nominee back in 2012
we welcome you Mr Speaker it's good to
see you again good to see you again good
to have you here thanks for having me
nice to be with you so we're saying you
know he's getting support from a lot of
fellow Republicans are you one of those
that are going Donald Trump is my guy
and no I've been a never again Trump for
some time now yeah so no I'm not I'm not
a trump fan uh I want to win and if we
nominate Trump we're going to lose uh we
hasn't won anything since 2016. we lost
the house in 18 we lost the presidency
in 20 we've lost the Senate we would
have won the Senate this time in 22 had
it not been for Trump and his his
nominees and some of our key primary
elections and my guess is we probably
would have picked up 10 to 15 seats in
the house if it weren't for you know his
involvement well you know when Marco
Rubio was here yesterday he said
something very interesting he said even
if Trump did something wrong you have to
weigh that against a harm indicting him
could already cause a divided country
what do you think about that way of
thinking I think this I think this one's
different I think you could make that
case for this New York prosecutor that
one seemed I mean look it's a never
again Trump that seemed pretty Petty and
political I can't help but think of his
name was Don Smith he probably wouldn't
have had that indictment this one's
National Security this one's different I
used to have these same documents myself
um as Speaker of the House so I think
this goes beyond just um some petty
thing now my guess is Trump will play
this politically pretty well and make
this weaponization argument and make
this about Joe Biden's justice
department and that's going to have some
political saliency so I don't think
Marco's wrong in saying that there's
some political sting here but I can't
help but think the weight and the
baggage of all of this and this one's
National Security this one I think we
want a nominee who's not weighed down
with so much baggage in order to win
this election and it's really clear a
lot of our Suburban voters will not vote
for Donald Trump I can tell you how it
works in Wisconsin I can't imagine
Donald Trump winning Wisconsin he lost
it in 20 and do you think he's done
things since 2020 election like January
6 that make those swing voters want to
vote for him but why do you think he's
trying to help the support that he has
though because he has a very good core
of support and he's got a good it's as
simple as that he's got a great core of
support in in in in a primary that is
what you build off of and so it does
matter but my point is I think the
electability argument is going to become
more Salient with with this indictment
and whatever happens in the future all
the exhaustion of all the Trump baggage
is going to make it easier now I think
to make the argument to his core
supporters he's not electable he's going
to cost us the Senate again he's going
to cost us more House Seats it'll cost
us the White House and we want to win
and we do want to win yeah so in this so
go look at what are these other great
conservatives that are in the race who
don't have all this baggage I think if
we nominate anybody not named Donald
Trump we're going to beat Joe Biden okay
we got to nominate somebody who would
that be we follow any one of these
candidates anyone anyone yeah anyone I
don't know the Vivid guy so but what I
know Nikki I know Chris they're all
people we know well right it's too early
in my opinion to start this is my own
perspective to pick somebody in the
primary to support
but I think there are plenty of people I
think Tim Scott Rhonda Sanders Nikki
Haley Mike Pence Chris Christie they're
all in the race they're very viable
people and I honestly believe any one of
them could beat Joe Biden if they become
the nominee and with the exception of
Chris Christie I don't hear from those
others the direct Trump cannot win we
need better argument that you make so
clearly I think I think people are
probably waiting just I think there's a
timing to that I don't think you can get
this nomination without going through
Donald Trump I don't think you can get
it going around him I think he had to go
through him to get the nomination Chris
is I mean Chris is unique in the in his
style but I think others will start
making that kind of what are they
waiting for though with all the other
people to get in the race so it's a
group thing the thing with Trump is he's
so vindictive that if you have a future
in front of you that you envisioned in
the Republican party you start with your
base you have to win a primary and if
that vindictiveness gets trained on you
it's sort of like the eye of Sauron
going after you yeah um it will make it
more difficult for you to succeed where
you are you know what it's like to be
attacked by yeah I don't but I don't
care anymore it's not yeah I I'm not
looking for anything I don't have
political ambition and so that is fairly
liberating and so it and so that's why
people like me make an electability
argument which is
to his supporters let's win we win by
stitching our Coalition together the
Maga Coalition and the Suburban base
those two right there give us
presidencies and House and Senate
majorities and if we go with Trump that
fractures it's just that as the race
becomes more crowded doesn't that work
as an advantage for Trump
it does it so the question is do people
get out of the race in time for first
for we for us to Galvanize around
somebody let's let people go test
themselves let's go see who gets
traction it's it's fine having people
enter the race and see if they do well
the question is come I don't know super
Tuesday right does it feel get shrunken
enough that let's just say Trump gets 33
consistently I don't know what the
number is and the rest of it is is
divided by six people then Trump's going
to get the nomination but if people try
don't get traction then get out of the
race and we have one or two people
making up the rest of that vote
Coalition that's 66 then I think that
person gets the nomination I think that
is that's how I want to see this play
out I think it's reasonable to think
that that's definitely what could happen
but at the same time yeah I mean Trump
if you had to like take a linear
projection from the election from where
we are today he's he's primed to win the
primary things aren't linear in politics
it's never a straight line so I just
don't think that's the way it's going to
go well he's going he's got a lot of
support right now according to all our
polls a lot of those supporters are
probably viewers of Fox News and
shifting topics here a little bit Fox
paid this huge settlement 800 million
dollars uh because uh of alleged lies
about Dominion in the discovery in what
was made public we saw that many
Executives and anchors at Fox were
saying things to their viewers their
millions of viewers that they were not
saying privately they were spreading
lies and they were doing so knowingly
you're on the board you know where this
is going yeah did you think to yourself
at some point E I don't want to be
involved in this no I'm down no if if I
think Fox News is a very important part
of the conservative movement and if you
want the conservative movement uh to be
going in the right direction then Fox
News can have a big hand in that so I
don't want to comment on on what is a
legal issue you know frankly because I'm
a board member
um but there's a big difference between
a big hand and an honest no but I don't
want to get into the Tit for Tad with it
but the point is you think about
stepping the point is the conservative
no I did not think about check me down
the point is the conservative movement
is a big movement and and the
conservative movement right now is going
through lots of turmoil and churn and
change and I think Donald Trump is the
middle of that Tempest I think if we get
past Donald Trump I think the
conservative movement will be viable and
majoritarian we have proven recently
that we can get majorities and win
presidencies I don't think we can with
Trump but if we get past Trump I believe
we the conservative movement Republican
party can get our majorities back we
barely have a majority in the house it's
four seats it's it's it's technical we
don't have a majority in the Senate we
should have this next election I think
it's uh it's 33 people are up 23 or
something like that senators are
Democrats we should get the majority in
this next election but if but if we
nominate Trump it's we're going to leave
seats on the table we may not get the
Senate majority if we nominate Trump
again so my point is
as as a guy who's a fan of Fox News
Fox News is a big part of this Fox News
and the whole constellation of the
conservative movement the Republican
movement if we can get ourselves as a
party in a movement past Trump we're
going to start winning majorities again
I think can I get your thoughts on that
movement just quickly I know we have to
go but Republican lawmakers around the
country are pushing legislation when it
comes to Banning books it could be trans
rights call it anti-walker however you
want to label it is that a good approach
a good strategy or a football fan is
that the way you should approach yeah
I'm not a cultural guy I think it's
really polarizing look on some of these
issues outside uh you know with the
anti-wolf crowd but to me I'm worried
about a debt crisis I'm worried about
you know the future of our country and
and China there are big policy problems
that we need to tackle if we want to
have a great 21st century for this
country
um my work at AEI Notre Dame and my
poverty Foundation is all about poverty
and upper Mobility you know what I worry
about are the big policy challenges that
are going unresolved or made worse by
Joe Biden so that's why I want to win
this election so we can actually fix
these big policy problems cultural War
politics is good primary election
politics it's very divisive but it's
effective politics it's effective
politics I'll grant you that but for me
I'm an old Jack Kemp guy I believe an
inclusive aspirational politics solve
problems we got we got huge problems
yeah so we're getting a debt crisis
we've got to get on top of that neither
Biden or Trump are good on this issue so
both of these people but you're saying
Mr speakers you missed the day-to-day of
Washington yeah
I hear the long 13 years ago you and
Kevin McCarthy wrote a book called Young
Guns the future of conservative
leadership what's amazing is you're
still so young
wow that was in the tip of your tongue
Paul Ryan thank you very much